Speaker 1: Continuing his attack on Nikki Haley.
I now want to highlight for you a truly hilarious
and also completely unbelievable and kind of
self owning statement that Donald Trump made
about Nikki Haley. Let me back it up. Nikki Haley
worked for Donald Trump's administration. And what
I mean by that is Donald Trump made Nikki Haley,
ambassador to the United Nations for the United
States. And Trump has a long history of saying,
I hire the best people that I that's one of the
things I do. I hire the absolute best people. It
was a joke. Trump hired some of the worst people
and regularly had to fire them and claim that
they were actually bad people and he was somehow
duped or they were good but then became bad. Or,
you know, he had to explain, How did you hire
all these bad people? Fine. So one of the issues
here is how is Trump going to attack Nikki Haley,
given that Trump was positive enough about
Nikki Haley to hire her and make her part of
his administration? Well, Trump's new line, which
he is talking about, of course, on his platform,
truth, social truth Central, is he hired her to be
an ambassador to help the people of South Carolina
by getting her out of South Carolina. This is I
mean, it's truly amazing stuff. Trump posting to
truth Social Quote. The greatest thing Nikki Haley
did for our country and the great state of South
Carolina was accepting the position of United
Nations ambassador so that the incredible then
Lieutenant Governor Henry McMaster, could be the
governor of South Carolina, where he has done an
absolutely fantastic. A job. That was a big reason
why I appointed Nikki to the position. It was a
favor to the people I love in South Carolina. This
is, of course, absurd gaslighting. Think about
what Trump wants you to believe. He thought of
Trump was sitting there when he became president.
Thinking to himself, okay, let's say Nikki
Haley's a terrible governor. I want to help
the people of South Carolina. So the way I'm
going to help the people of South Carolina
is I'm going to make Nikki Haley ambassador,
even though she's a terrible elected official.
Just to get her out of South Carolina in order
to help that state by making Henry McMaster the
governor. This is idiocy. Nobody would believe
that this is what Donald Trump did. But the real
story here is it's only February of the year
before the election. It's not February 20, 24,
and it's getting this insane. It's February
20, 23, and it's already completely bonkers
and insane. This is going to get way crazier and
just wait until more people get into this race.